merci la parole est un monsieur gilles
lurton
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre du
travail et de l'emploi
madame la ministre l'augmentation
ininterrompue des chiffres du chômage
depuis le début de ce quinquennat s'est
encore aggravée au mois d'août
plus de 750 mille jeunes restent sans
emploi ni formation bien au-dessus de la
moyenne européenne
nous avons dans notre pays un taux de
chômage des 15 24 ans très supérieur à
celui de l'allemagne des pays bas ou du
royaume uni selon l'organisation de
coopération et de développement
économiques
ces pays ont fait le choix de
l'association des études du travail en
encourageant le développement de
l'apprentissage
l'allemagne comme le royaume uni ont
mené une réforme de l'apprentissage de
grande ampleur depuis 2009 en intégrant
les principes fondamentaux de
performances et d'autonomie
les résultats sont là dans ces pays les
chômage diminue pour ce qui vous
concerne vous avez fait le choix dès le
début du quinquennat de privilégier la
montée en puissance des emplois d'avenir
10 milliards d'euros y ont été consacrés
au détriment de l'apprentissage qui
pourtant constitue une véritable
insertion vers l'emploi
dans un rapport du mois d'octobre la
cour des comptes dénonce un
enchevêtrement de dispositifs qui
concerne majoritairement le secteur non
marchand et qui sont générateurs de
dépenses publiques sans créer d'activité
les formations pour ce type de contrats
ne sont pas suivis parce qu'elles ne
produisent aucune qualification
c'est ce que nous n'avons cessé de
dénoncer depuis le début du quinquennat
mais malgré les conclusions de ce
rapport vous persistez alors que la cour
des comptes demande de redéployer les
crédits vers des dispositifs
d'accompagnement plus efficace comme
l'apprentissage
alors madame la ministre allez vous
suivre les conclusions de ce rapport et
prendre exemple sur les autres pays
européens
merci la parole est à madame myriam el
khomri ministre du travail de l'emploi
la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur président
ces messieurs les députés monsieur le
député gilles lurton je n'ai pas
commencé par une bataille des chiffres
en effet nous faisons partie de la
moyenne haute en europe en terme de
chômage des jeunes mais par contre j'ai
une appréciation qui est différente de
la vôtre c'est que nous sommes à un
niveau
s'agissant du chômage des jeunes je le
dis ici précisément à un niveau
quasiment stable par rapport à mai 2012
néanmoins nous sommes en effet dans une
moyenne haute et la réalité
à partir de là qu'est ce que nous avons
mis en oeuvre nous avons clairement
travailler sur la question de
l'orientation scolaire et notamment de
lutter contre les jeunes qui sortent du
système scolaire sans qualification
nous sommes passés en effet 250 milles à
110 mille jeunes qui sont d'inite tous
les ans donc c'est un point qui est
essentiel et nous y travaillons avec la
ministre de l'éducation nationale
deuxième aspect la formation en effet il
faur porter un regard critique sur notre
pays en matière de formation et nous
savons que la question de l'accès à un
niveau de qualification et porter
derrière bien évidemment sur le marché
de l'emploi
donc à partir de là dans le cadre par
exemple du plan 500000 formation
supplémentaire que nous mettons en
oeuvre avec les présidents de régions
que nous portons avec clotilde valter et
les partenaires sociaux 25% de ces
formations sont en direction des jeunes
notamment pour lutter contre cela et
puis nous avons mis en place dans le
rapport de la cour des comptes il ya une
autre donnée qui n'ont pas pris en
compte les dommages puisque avait un
rapport de la dares qui est sorti le 5
octobre dernier qui montrait bien que
trois jeunes sur quatre en emplois
d'avenir ont bénéficié d'une formation
et que la moitié ont bénéficié d'une
formation certifiante et c'est bien sûr
essentielle et puis il ya la garantie
jeunes dans le cadre de la loi travail
nous avons porté deux choses la première
c'est l'obligation de publier les taux
d'insertion sur les voies de formation
qui est un élément important pour
l'orientation et bien sûr sur
l'apprentissage pour valoriser de ce
point de vue là et nous avons depuis une
entrée + 5 % d'entrée en apprentissage
donc nous continuons justement